-Guys, did you ever see
a photo in the news
and think the headline could
be much better?
Well, I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "News & Improved."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "News & Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline
can definitely be improved,
because if you only
look at the photo,
the headline could have been...
Uh...May 6th.
-No.
-May 7th.
-May 8th?
-No.
-Is it in May?
-Check out
this -- Is your name May?
-No.
-Have you ever met anyone
named May?
-No. Well, once.
-Good night, everybody.
Check out this next photo.
The original headline was...
If you only looked at the photo,
the headline could've been...
"Don't --
Mama needs her Franzia!"
The next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
It's like...
"I'll be wearing
a bright-orange blazer."
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Wow!
-That's terrible.
-ABBA?
-Mamma mia!
-Yeah. Up next,
this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Chuckles ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
The shower?
Drinking in the shower?
-Six shower beers? Wow!
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Oh, yeah.
"Freaking out!"
Finally, this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That is all the time we have for
"News & Improved"!